في الاثناء تنشط تحركات اقليميه ودوليه من
اجل وقف الصراحه المسلح الدائر بين الجيش
السوداني بقياده الفريق الاول عبد الفتاح
البرهان رئيس مجلس السياده وقوات الدعم
السريع بقياده نائبه وحليفه السابق الفريق
محمد حمدان
رئيس المفوضيه الافريقيه موسى فكي شجب
وصول الاحداث في السودان الى الوضع الراهن
ودعا الجيش والدعم السريع لوقف تدمير
البلاد وسفك الدماء في العشر الاواخر من
رمضان على حد قوله من ناحيتها دعت بعثه
الامم المتحده الخاصه في السودان الى
التهدئه الفوريه وندد مبعوث المنظمه
الدوليه في الخرطوم فولكربرتس بشده
باندلاع القتال ودعا لسرعه وقفه ومدع ومنع
المزيد من تداعياته
اما الولايات المتحده فاعتبر التحول
التوترات المتزايده داخل المكون العسكري
في السودان الى قتال مباشر امرا في غايه
الخطوره وحث وزير خارجيه جميع الاطراف على
وقف العنف فورا وتجنب التعبئه تعبئه
القوات ودعا للتفاوض لحل القضايا العالقه
وادعت وزاره الخارجيه البريطانيه البرهان
وحمايه الى كبح جماح الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وتخفيف التصعيد لمنع المزيد من
اراقه الدماء كما اعربت روسيا عن قلقها من
تصاعد التوتر بين الجيش والدعم السريع
ودعت لاتخاذ اجراءات عاجله لوقف اطلاق
النار والقبول الفوري للجهود الراميه في
جمع الطرفين من في مائده مفاوضات